of all the great movie lines and made
him an offer he couldn't refuse you were
only supposed to blow the bloody doors
off just one seems right for this week
is from Basha in Ocean's eleven you
tossers
you had one job to do two years on from
the EU referendum Mrs May is heading for
Brussels looking for a unicorn Jeremy
Corbyn having initially refused to talk
to the government reveals that actually
he's got nothing to say everybody else
is kicking the can down the road in the
hope that somebody else will sort things
out the public's faith in our democracy
must be in freefall
I fear that our floundering Parliament
is opening Britain to the right-wing
authoritarianism we're seeing across the
continent maybe it's time to think again
about the way we do politics
let's start by banning the party whip
system and making mp's vote according to
their conscience 'as I know it'll mean
that the poor things will have to
actually think for themselves Hey surely
the mother of parliament can do better
than this you know it's interesting
Trevor you're saying what a lot of
people have said what a lot of
commentators have said that mrs. Mae and
the British government of been kicking
the can down the road I would argue that
last wheel this week or the other night
they kick the can firmly in the
direction of Brussels on Claude Jung
Cagiva off shut Michelle Bernie at Al
and the reaction has been quite
interesting in that understandably
understandably they've said that there
is no movement on the back stop we've
heard promises from the European Union
before but if we can so make that point
if we come to your central point I think
you're right and I've said before we
look at the 650 people to whom we pay
more than 77,000 pounds a year they
lecture us about how we need national
nor national unity I think possibly
they've sowed the seeds of division far
greater than any other organized
organization I can think of and I think
your idea of taking away the party
initially when you said it I think poor
old Trev he's gone bonkers always been
on the sherry trifle again but Shirley
actually it could lead to some really
really fascinating votes but but for the
first time in a long time
I thought I saw at least a hint of
clarity this week with mrs. mate I don't
think that's true
thing what they you know there this is a
new way of kicking the can down the road
let's create something which we know
that you are going to reject and so that
afterwards we can say hold up its the in
tragedy new and then we I promise on you
we march on towards we march on towards
no deal just for balance and I promise I
should Trevor the EU said they would
never bail out a foreign country that
was in the eurozone currency they bailed
you cannot count the amount of money
they poured towards Greece the back end
of last year they bailed out an Italian
bank because that Italian back both
France and German banks have enormous
exposure the European the EU could say
we're never going to do this and in fact
they do it's very much the modus
operandi are you wishful thinking I mean
to Greece on the verge of bankruptcy
says it all I don't think they're
kicking the can down the road they
exploded the can and invented a new can
that doesn't even exist what are they
thinking I was abroad this week so I was
watching this from a distance so I'd get
the updates at the end of the day and it
was like reading the scripts of a horror
film yeah I mean I really feel that it's
not that complicated
we need Parliament to actually come up
with a solution grounded in reality you
can't conduct a negotiation by voting
something that is not an offer
it's just a negotiating tactic that
doesn't exist for a reason and that's
because they want two things even no
deal or to force Parliament to vote for
her deal in the end that's what this is
about so you guys are going straight
into the same hole let's attack the
Tories my institution has failed to do
your 650 whatever it is heads together
and come up with a pathway every what's
happening now is that everybody is busy
backpedaling and trying to find a hole
that means that whatever comes out
nobody's gonna blame them they are not
doing the job right I'd say that some
people are actually trying to give us
bread to about leaving his brakes it's
just gonna be remain under a different
bearer barrier do not mean they're not
yielding there's a completely bending
over and taking
we do not want that we've heard from the
wannabe Tory let's hear from a Tory MP
I'm afraid it's gang support because I
think there are some of my colleagues
who are more concerned with the unity of
the Conservative Party than what's in
the best interests of the country so as
far as I'm concerned they they might as
well have been a called a King Canute
amendment that we can all legislate to
turn turn back the tide but I'm afraid
we're not going to see a change to the
legal texts or the withdrawal agreements
but that's a good example of
sanctimonious nonsense she still hasn't
told us what should happen yeah but once
the people spoke about nobody's yet
saying may not remain deal no deal
what's here the people's vote is about
do you want her deal or or do you want
us to keep with what we've got
that's what the people on the subject of
the deal to underscore the point that
you've made Trevor and to prove that I
was paying attention in geography
lessons please bring on Alan and Freddy
Freddy will disprove they disprove the
notion that you have to be glamorous to
work in television so we can lay that to
bed once and for all
I am now going to put crosses on the map
of places that have rejected
renegotiating the brexit deal in Belgium
EU Council President Donald Tusk the
back stop is part of the withdrawal
agreement it is not open for
renegotiation Republic the withdrawal
agreement is not open for renegotiation
there we are
France macron the deal is quotes the
best possible is not renegotiate go to
from this is very much underscoring your
point you're making I know I'm Germany
Manfred Weber close ally of Angela
Merkel everything is reopened we talk
again about Gibraltar Fisheries policies
how much Britain must pay a very stern
attitude this is World War two
[Laughter]
the president we are not ready to
renegotiate the exit agreement and
lastly the Netherlands the Prime
Minister Mark Rutte er the present deal
is the only deal on the table Freddy and
Alan I am now known as Friedrich thank
you very much we have to have the
courage to take a decision rather than
simply saying everything that everybody
wants is wrong because if we don't make
a decision and frankly at the moment the
decision is only Mays deal or something
like it or no deal that's gonna be our
choice what what I resent about what our
parliamentarians are doing is they are
basically shirking it and putting it
back to the people it's just the best
way of shirking your duty and I bring in
what
trucha had to say on this let's have a
look at one of these MPs you're talking
about if people are going to keep voting
against motions designed to stop this
country from crashing out of the
European Union with no deal if they're
going to vote against motions and
potentially legal motions as well with
teeth then that is definitely now more
of a possibility than it was at the
start of today I think you'd be very
clear no yeah but he won in 650 so you
got one more Joker's got guts
but essentially his party doesn't dump
the B word for at least five minutes
time and let's talk about sound we can
do something about